Hello!
Hey everyone!
Oh my god!
Why are we here right now?
All four of us back again!
Whoa!
I told... It's a real mystery.
Oh my god, we're gonna finally find out why we were in
Korea!
Oh!
You guys went to Korea?
Oh wait.
Any guesses?
I wonder if you have any guesses.
I did?
People think we were there for a league.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was what you think.
you know what this girl behind us john fake is gonna walk
right out of there right now we're gonna be on the baker's
team guys i have so many comments going they're joining t1 i
know it i fucking knew it oh my god there's nothing else it
could be t1 is making a vtuber company oh guys come on i
don't even play a league i don't play that's the nearest
people league
Oh my god, we're gonna play with Faker guys We call V1.
Oh my god.
That's actually Oh wait, you're so funny.
You're flying too close to the sun with that one You can't
send fate.
It's not right.
It's not flying close to the sun if we're in T1 though It's
true true true.
You know who's pretty close to the sun right now faker in
one of his wizard towers good for him Good for him That's
gonna be us in that wizard tower.
Yeah, that's gonna be us.
We're gonna have our own wizard tower do you remember in the
in our contract win you know when we that we signed we're
gonna have our own each of us are gonna have our very own
wizard tower right now if i sign onto this honestly i just
want real the four towers it's like lord of the rings we got
registered we registered a copy of everyone it's already
been registered That's why, that's what we're announcing.
Oh my god.
You can't say that it's way too early.
John Finker wanted us to stay, he wanted us to stall for
like another 40 minutes, like minimum.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
We gotta stall for another 30 to 40 minutes, guys.
Yeah.
Imagine if we did.
It's gonna be a lot of teasing.
Yeah, it's a lot of edging.
Don't worry, I just finished watching the World Cup.
That was basically what I had to go through today.
Well, whatever you do on your own time, it's your own
business.
But like, I won't be so, what if we just get a message from
the server to be like, please hurry up?
Like, oh my God.
They're just going to send like the please wrap it up thing.
Like, guys, guys, the music starts to get louder and louder,
like the Oscars.
Yeah, it's like the Oscars are going to play us off before
we even announce it.
They're just going to like, they're just going to announce
it themselves.
You're like, and the reason is, and it's like, today's
sponsor is brought to you by.
brought to you by t1 apparently yeah v1 actually v1 that's
our name i'm nervous right now guys i'm so i don't know why
are you guys feeling nervous you hold my hand everyone's
gonna be disappointed by like the real project because like
that no that's a real good bit we just got going guys i
don't worry guys i make sure everybody's expectation is
really really high that's no way this can backfire did you
see my tweet i was like the biggest announcement in my
career ever.
I did see that.
I was like, whoa!
Oh, I see it, though.
I see it.
Wait, I just put announcements.
We need to talk.
It sounds like I'm going to do like an apology.
We're all graduating and we're reincarnating as each other.
You're like crying in your gift.
Yeah, it's like all of us are graduating.
That's the...
Oh, snap.
Oh, I am glad to announce that I have been cast as Doki Bird
in the recently announced live action movie.
And I've been cast as Rin Penrose as well.
There's no way this can go wrong.
There's no way.
Oh, yeah.
No, but, yeah, no, but, oh, gosh.
You know how, like, we've been, like, teasing this for a
while now?
We did tell them it was going to be announced soon, but not
too soon.
And it's already, I was already here.
It's today.
Oh, God.
It feels like it's been five years.
You will finally find out what we've been working on.
I know.
It's actually crazy.
We can find, but, but we'll have to say, we can't tell,
unfortunately, We can't tell our full Korea story yet,
unfortunately, but we can tell a bit of it.
Like, it's like a slow trip.
We can tell some secrets, but there are still secrets left
to be told for the future.
It's an issue, but we're allergic to doing announcements
properly.
This is the best we got.
Cool.
It's like Christmas.
Like, you found the gifts early.
We're going to let you open one.
You know?
It's a slow trip.
Don't get too comfy.
New Year's isn't a week.
Boxing Day!
Yay!
Yeah.
It's like, Something to box, all right.
We're slowly feeding you little by little, the crumbs of
everything.
And they got baby birds.
It's like we're going to play an ARG.
Like, we're going to play an ARG right now and slowly got to
uncover the mystery of what we're trying to announce.
There had to be an easier way to go about this, I say, as
we're like 15 years into the project and still no one knows
what we're actually doing.
It's like video one out of 500.
Good luck, everyone.
Oh, my God.
And he goes back to the part 15 of our teaser reveals.
Yeah, part 15.
Are you going to announce it now?
We're going to reveal the next letter.
It's like the wheel of fortune.
Holy shit.
Double you.
No way.
Roll for a vowel.
Would you like to buy a countdown?
Would you like to buy a vowel?
Can I leave her?
Like.
We play hangman with chat.
We're like, What could it be?
We're getting a TV show.
Finally, I get to be a game show home so I can die now.
Like this was actually the announcement.
We're playing Hang Mang.
We're playing.
That would actually be very clever.
Yeah.
Play Wheel of Fortune.
We have a secret fifth member.
Give me an eye.
The price is not in fact right.
Oh my God.
All right.
It's time to announce the announcement.
Yeah.
I was going to announce the announcement.
I was going to say, do we bait them more?
Do we just rip it?
I don't know.
Chad keeps telling me, stop.
I saw someone go, I'm going to bed.
Some of my chats, like, give me a night, buddy.
Say the magic word, Chad.
I'm like, you never know.
Just because you guys want to know.
He's just ruined it for everyone now, I'm afraid.
Yeah, it's like, is this an announcement?
You know, those, like, trailers where they're, like, a
trailer announcement for the trailer?
Yeah, like a pre-announcement.
Yeah, the pre-trail, the teaser, the teaser for the trailer
where they announce the date of when the trailer's gonna
drop.
Why didn't we think of that, dammit?
Oh my god, we should have done that, guys.
We should have just, the video we should have played.
We're absolutely sick of this.
We just want to know what the project is.
For God's sake, it's been months.
Massey, are you ready?
All right, I'll give us a countdown.
Drum roll, please.
Give us a show, everybody.
I'll give us a countdown.
Everybody spam their emotes.
Dance.
We played at the same time.
Yeah, yeah, we play at the same time.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
All right, in five, four, three, two, one.
The Wild Card Club.
Hello, my name is Amelie, and I am one of the captains of
the Wild Card Club.
Hi, my name is Rin Penrose, and I am one of the captains of
Hello, I'm Iron Mouse, and I'm one of the four captains of
the Wild Card Club.
My name is Doki Bird.
I'm one of the captains of the wildcard club.
It's really nice to meet you guys.
I think it's gonna be such a fun club.
I'm very excited to meet some new people and make something
together.
I was a bit confused because no one ever asks me to join on
things.
They never chose me for the sports team at school.
What's going on?
Oh my god, I was like, me with responsibility.
Is that gonna be good or bad?
I was like, I'm gonna try my best to be the best captain
that I can be.
And I wanted to give you a- No… I'm not done yet.
Oh wait, wait.
Can I say one more thing?
I want to hang out with you.
Please come by.
Please join the club Mmmhhh.
Welcome to the Wild Card Club!
Hello, my name is Amelie and I am one of the captains of the
wild card club.
Hi, my name is Rin Penrose and I am one of the captains of
the wild card club.
Hello, I'm Iron Mouse and I'm one of the four captains of
My name is Doki Bird.
I'm one of the captains of the wildcard club.
It's really nice to meet you guys.
I think it's gonna be such a fun club.
I'm very excited to meet some new people and make something
together.
I was a bit confused because no one ever asks me to join on
things.
They never chose me for the sports team at school.
What's going on?
Oh my god, I was like, me with responsibility?
Is that gonna be good or bad?
I was like, I'm gonna try my best to be the best captain
that I can be.
and I wanted to give you a big, big...
Mouse!
Mouse, are you done yet?
I'm not done yet!
Oh, wait, wait, can I say one more thing?
I want to hang out with you!
Please come by!
Join the club!
Alright, hey!
Sorry to my chat.
Mousey muted her video, so we had to rewind time.
Sorry, guys.
We were being too loud over it.
We like to talk.
Yeah, we're like the people Be quiet.
We're like the people who are watching in them.
I'm already swat back.
Let's just have it looping in the background.
So, are they still watching it?
Or are they like the people who chat in the movies and being
like, oh, hey, guys.
Wait, why do you talk?
These kids on their damn phones.
Wait, what's happening?
I'm trying to watch the movie.
Okay, I will stuff my mouth with popcorn.
Are they watching again?
Yeah.
I'm gonna play it again.
Another one.
You wanna do a countdown?
All right, we'll do a countdown.
Guys, you guys want, you know what's better than a second
time?
Watching it a third time.
True.
Find all the hidden letters in this trailer.
All right.
All right, I need to bring up Rin a little bit.
My sound guys say, all right, sound guys, let me know if
everybody's sound great.
All right, guys, we'll watch it a third time.
Guys, I'll do a countdown.
I'll see.
Five, four, three, two, one.
The World Card Club.
My name is Amelie and I am one of the captains of the Wild
Card Club.
Hi, my name is Rin Penrose and I am one of the captains.
Or captains of the Wild Card Club.
My name is Doki Bird.
I'm one of the captains of the Wild Card Club.
It's really nice to meet you guys.
I think it's going to be such a fun club.
I'm very excited to meet some new people and make something
together.
I was a bit confused because no one ever asks me to join on
things.
They never chose me for the sports team at school what's
going on oh my god i was like me with responsibility is that
gonna be good or bad i was i'm gonna try my best to be the
best captain that i can be and i wanted to give you a big
big mouse mouse are you done yet i'm not done yet oh wait
wait can i say one more thing i want to hang out with you
please come by please join the club yes so quiet yay okay
we're so quiet I was ready to explode.
Wait, okay, wait, I shouldn't.
I'm sorry.
Does anyone have the URL of the YouTube channel right now?
Did none of us prepare this?
I can find it.
Oh my God, did none of us get this ready ahead of time?
It's okay.
I looked it up.
I got it.
There's already 212 views.
Oh my God, people found it already.
People already had time when we played it for the third
time.
That's true.
That might be where they got it.
Oh, that might be where they go.
I mean, I didn't see anyone in my chat finding it, like,
before the stream.
So, I'm pinning the channel right now, but, yes, we're the
Wild Card Club.
Yay!
I do think people are confused.
What is the Wild Club card?
All right, let's grab the...
Wild Club side.
I see you when you go into checkboxes.
I mean, that's one of them.
It's not a meal deal, right?
all right all right i want to make sure it's like not too
nice now let me just pull up our notes real quick we have no
okay if i sound scripted it's because it's not scripted i'm
just really bad at improv i you got this champ i believe i
believe so what is the wild card club so we are all here
together because a global music company asked the four of us
to take on a captain role for this project.
We can't share who that is just yet, but...
It's John Music himself.
Yes, you can hear John Music.
But you'll find four of us at Off-Kai.
We have a very, very special panel and event at Off-Kai
dedicated to the Wild Card Club.
It's a very big event, too.
And it's a collaborative project with many people
contributing their ideas and helping it shape along the way.
But Doki, that still doesn't answer what the wild card club
is.
Well, why don't you tell us?
Why don't Amelie tell us?
I know you took notes.
Yeah, you literally bragging about the notes you tell.
Yeah, you were like, yeah, I took notes of everything.
You said everything I already took notes.
Oh, have any notes.
I didn't mean any notes.
Okay, okay, you know what?
Don't worry, Amelie.
I got you.
The wild and wild card club stands for wildly disorganized.
wild card the wild club got wild card club you got this you
got it four times the charm four times the charm guys the
wild card club is a music focused project created with
vtubers it begins with four of us me amalie amos and rin and
it follows the journey of recruiting vtubers to join them
forming new teams and creating original music together yay
so it's not just us four it's also there's going to be more
more of us but it's up to you guys to join us in the future
whose team do you want to be on yeah so we're gonna be part
of teams kind of thing yeah it's a team's thing so we're all
technically i'm against all of you but friendly friendly but
friendly friendly friendly friendly competition yeah so i
could talk about this so basically oh yeah but Anyway,
you're going to find out who the secret thing behind us is,
like who the secret global music company is on Off-Kai.
So you guys are curious who it is.
It could be anyone.
It could be anyone in this room.
We will all be John Faker himself.
It's probably not, but you know.
And we'll all be streaming that panel as well.
So even if you're not coming to Off-Kai in person, though if
you are, we'd love to see you there.
Don't worry, we'll be streaming that panel as well.
well so you can be there for the moment that we fully
announce everything so don't worry don't there won't be any
fomo or anything because all of our channels will be
restreaming the panel as well so you can catch up on what
the wild card club is yeah i watched that trailer three
times and all but i'm still confused yeah oh yeah and also
um so a little bit like a preview uh so each of us will be
tackling a specific genre as a captain so uh i will be as a
little preview um i will be girl band uh so yeah a little
girl band is my genre love it that suits you really well i
know i know you know like um what they they got inspired by
they they reached out to me only because of the girlfriend
cover i did oh yeah yeah so that's what i said they're like
oh think girl ben is like perfect for you and i was like oh
i was like no i was like no no critiques whatsoever i agree
like it's way cooler my thing because i'm pretty sure they
just dialed the wrong number and like somehow they got
through to me no no come out you've literally released more
communication they haven't figured it out they haven't
figured it out it's gonna be okay I'm gonna make this walk
What else What else Do we have to talk about?
Mine's gonna have Some Latina flavor Oh yeah Wait really?
Yeah I remember that Yeah I remember During the meeting we
had It's gonna be really fun And you'll find out What Rin
and Amelie's Are gonna be During Amelie's to say My club
will have The least amount of scuff though I'm calling it
now Mine will have Amelie's the absolute full ideas from me
during our during our trip what no this is this is an
absolute blast no no no i have witnesses she had she really
plagiarized one of my assignments at korea in korea yeah
yeah no yeah it definitely didn't happen where i was like we
should do this and then doki louder went yeah we should do
this anyway that was my idea copyright doki break I think
I'll see you in court, Dogey.
But maybe you should have said it louder.
What can I say?
I'm quietly under my breath with golden ideas.
And Dogey's like, I'm listening to every word.
Oh, see, my dog agrees with me.
Hey.
No.
Oh, it's right.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
Also, like, by the way, we almost forgot there is a
documentary.
Yay.
There is a documentary.
By the way.
Sorry, my dog reminded me about it.
In what possible way?
He was telling me about the documentary.
That's why he was barking.
That's what the trailer was for that we just played.
Of course.
Documentary.
I understand now.
It'll make sense.
Yeah, the trailer was for the documentary that's going to
document the entire journey of the wildcard club.
So there's going to be a whole bunch of us.
So we can talk about the 3D mocap that we did.
did for this documentary.
Dude, that was so cool.
That was actually my very first time in a mocap suit, like,
ever.
I've been in one once before, but not to film like that.
And it was just like, especially for my V-Tuber.
So it was like really, really cool to be a part of.
Insane.
Have you guys been in the suits before like that?
Yeah, yeah, I've been.
Well, about you.
One time.
I know, Brent.
I know you have.
You've done my pocket.
Exactly one time.
Um, I think it was very funny.
Okay, it might not be very funny for you, Rin.
I'm really sorry what happened to you for that.
Wait, hold on.
What happened to me?
I didn't know.
Wait, what is it, Massey?
What's happening?
Massey, what's happening?
Okay, you fixed.
You're not crunchy anymore.
Oh, am I not?
If I deconched, am I deconched?
I'm not crunchy.
You crunchy, are we crunchy?
So, I think the funniest part for, I thought, during the
whole 3D mocap experience, but it wasn't funny for Rin
during that, What was we had a test.
It was harrowing for me, apparently.
No, you'll remember the way I tell this story.
You're going to remember the trauma.
Oh, no.
The subtle thing this could be.
I'm just going to narrow down the list as you keep talking.
It was when, when, you know how we all had a test footage?
We had to do test.
Oh, yeah, Moussey wasn't there, but we'll tell you the
story.
I was not there.
But we were doing test footage of everything.
And she was making sure like all the suits fit and stuff and
like all our 3D models work.
So, each of us, we're supposed to sit on a chair to make
sure we don't clip through anything.
So, Amalie and I did that.
A little bit of foreshadowing here.
Rin decided to be like, what if I pick up this chair?
And I have a photo of this, but I can't share it yet.
No, I can.
I already asked for photos.
I can share it.
So, yeah, don't worry.
I got you.
I'm so jealous.
So, so, let me see if I can get it.
Let me grab the photo.
Hey, wait a second, I have free will.
Uh-oh.
That's one of my favorite photos of Rin just looming over
me.
Yeah, it's one of my best moments.
The chair is rigged in the 3D world.
So if you pick up the chair or do something with the chair,
the chair is visible with the model.
I'll send it to Mousy and she can show it too on her stream.
It's a good photo, Mousy.
You didn't see the photo before, but it's a good photo.
It's a...
Oh, oh, oh.
Never mind, oh, we might have all been evaporation.
on Mouse's phone.
Oh my god, that was so weird.
We all disappeared.
She's alone.
Bye, Mouse.
Here we are.
I posted a photo.
So, oh my god, that's so funny.
Yeah, it's so...
Because they're like posed.
They're like posed for us.
So good.
So, wait, can I show chat this?
Yeah, yeah, I already showed it.
How did you get this photo?
Because my photo in my, in my pure hag ability is a photo of
the screen.
Yeah, of the monitor.
How did you get a screenshot?
Because they sent us a folder of all the screenshots they
took up the monitor.
Yes, it's in the server.
Oh, my bad.
I literally have a photo of the screen.
I hate myself.
See, before we did a stream, they were like, good luck,
Jokia, on leading this.
You're like...
Uh-oh.
Yeah, anyway.
All right, so...
You can do an alt-f, yeah, yeah.
So...
And then comes Ren Penrose with the steel chair.
Yeah, I know.
Everyone's like, post-cule.
and Rin picks up a goddamn chair.
I'm like, cheese.
I tried kicking the chair as well, but it's one of those
with the connectors between the legs, so I just kind of
stumbled and fell over.
It's very memeable.
I want someone to like, can someone cut out Rin of this
photo and make her a transparent PNG so I can put her like,
Godzilla-sized in New York?
I'll expand it for everybody.
Transposed in New York.
So now you're, wondering why belongs to the people now why
is it a traumatic memory for rin well because she didn't sit
on the chair she didn't oh no because she didn't sit on the
chair we didn't realize that we have pants and rin does not
rin has a skirt oh i didn't think this was a problem we were
going to talk about because i didn't end up being an issue
when i was shooting my bit I ran into.
Yeah, yeah.
So the issue that I ran into was...
So the way they do facial mocap at this particular studio.
Can't go too much into it, mostly because I don't understand
and never will.
But the way that they wanted to do mocap for our faces, for
us, was basically, here is a bicycle helmet.
We put a tripod on it.
There is a phone on the end.
Good luck.
And I got in for my day of shooting.
All right, guys, it's time to be a professional.
how the hell did i get here and they sent me down on the
chair and they're like okay we're gonna put the helmet on
now having forgotten that they had forgotten probably
because i was just scaring them honestly to fit me for a
helmet so they put a helmet on me and oh that's too big you
had a tiny head don't worry we've got a smaller size we'll
put it on it's still too big okay um well we don't usually
use this one but we'll we'll stuff it full of newspapers and
it's still too It was crazy.
So in the end, they just kind of had to stick a tripod in
front of me and be like, please do not rotate your head too
much.
Everything will be right now.
You did not tell us that, Pirate!
Because I, oh my god!
I just knew you had helmet issues because like my head was
too big.
So I took Amelie's helmet.
I know, and then I got the smaller one.
Yeah, you got the shitty one.
I got the best helmet because...
Oh my god.
I've got a small head and I've got very broad shoulders.
I'm very masculine like that.
You must understand.
My cat is a small Victorian child.
Yeah, she is.
What do you just say about me?
Wait, how tall are you?
I don't want to talk about it at the present time.
Okay.
She is a Victorian child.
I'm very malnourished because they only have a femi cone.
Wait, are you taller than me?
Are you shorter than me?
How tall are you?
It depends.
She has malnutrition from Rin.
Wait, a little louder mouth.
Oh, I'm 14.
Yeah, okay, Rin, how about you?
Rin?
Oh, she has to convert.
She's converting.
She's British.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
In one yard stick tall.
It's two kegs of beer tall.
You're taller?
Yes.
Where is he taller?
Yes, as in.
Yes.
Yes, what?
Yes, as in which one?
This is all I will be saying at the present time.
Thank you.
Wait, we can ask her.
She can ask her.
manager we don't know how to convert from i'm 147
centimeters oh damn that's unfortunate for you i'm sorry oh
someone edit mouse as the chair being lifted and then um for
filming i got the i got the easiest job because i got
clocked out the earliest set of everybody yeah yeah nice for
some i got clocked wait a minute technically i never clock
you're right you never clock we got mousey got you are true
damn yeah she got the she got the easiest was i not the
first one in the suit i thought it was me no but then you
had to go do the other filming stuff remember oh yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah you have like a lot more there's a
reason they slow us all out more secrets you'll find out on
episode two or three or four whichever episode that is
someone someone in chat did ask when that off kai panel is
it's on say yeah we can it's on sunday i think yeah it would
have been p.m is that much week yeah it's sunday it's
literally next sunday again at uh at 12 p.m because the only
reason why i know is because i have a rivals tournament at
that time too so they're getting a they're getting a sub for
me in the rivals tournament i finish the panel i go back to
playing rival is i oh so funny that's hysterical that's the
only reason i know double duty over here like i clocked i
imagine like you're playing rivals with like your hands and
stuff and then with like some foot pedals you just try to
control yeah yeah i'm playing the stream i'm playing the
tournament game but i'm in the panel as well
We're doing the panel.
We just hear Doki go, Bp in the backline.
Yeah.
Bp on you.
I'm like muted.
And you guys are like, why is she muted right now?
I have two Discord accounts open so one can be in the VC and
one can be in this pack.
Oh, my God.
Pretty good.
It's pretty good.
Doki, what are you talking about music?
We're trying to push mid or whatever it is we do in this
game.
Push mid.
Mid.
Oh, God.
I don't go here.
I don't know.
Goal!
We got a goal!
Wait!
Oh, yeah, but yeah, anyway, so...
So, Rin and Amelie were stuck at the 3D mocap studio.
You're right back there?
The longest.
Yeah, sorry, he's just part of this now.
Yeah, he's part of this now.
The secret fifth member, oh no, the secret fifth member was
Faker, as we all know.
So this is the secret sixth member.
They're all related to Doki for some reason.
Oh!
Love it, I love it.
Oh, that's so cute.
Doki has a loading on her head.
Yeah, she went to goes offline.
She is phased out of existence.
She is really cute.
Yeah, but I remember when...
Oh, wait, what are you going to say?
Nope.
I was going to segue us.
Go right ahead.
Oh, yeah.
I was going to like to build on with that these two were
there the studio longest.
So I was supposed to drop by during Ryn's recording.
And I like texted the scene.
studio, and was like, when can I drop by?
And then—because I thought you were almost over, and then
they were like—I think I ran long.
Yeah, and they're like, we're still setting up the model
right now.
It's just like— Oh man.
Yeah, and I was just like—all right, I'm—I'm sitting at this
mall.
Oh, my 3D models are stupid, complicated, and no one knows
how to set them up, because they don't make sense, so we ran
long.
Yeah, I was just like—Why am I keep doing this?
I've got to get a better wardrobe.
I guess I'm going to stay at this mall, shopping then oh my
we did we did a lot i i personally did a lot of shopping on
the other days though oh that's true that's true i bought i
bought so much stuff like she like disappeared and bought
more stuff i know we me and my friend went out like late me
my manager went out like late at night to get even more
stuff is friend to manager an upgrade or a downgrade uh it's
good thing i wasn't there i would have stopped you you have
spent so much money massy well Yeah, that's a normal place.
I was like, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
There were so many gotchas stuff, too.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, God, yeah.
Yeah, I remember that.
The little pooping dog gotchas.
That one had my heart.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Little dogs and little, like, there are different dogs
taking poops.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, have you guys?
You guys seen the...
Okay, so we should pivot to the documentary.
We should pivot to the documentary right now.
Yes.
So, for the documentary, this is episode one, so we're
introducing the Wildcard Club.
Obviously, there's...
a lot of questions about it but for more details will be
announced during the off guy panel but i was when you know
because we all watched the documentary beforehand um so you
know because we have to get feedback and everything and i
you guys are so serious with your what your interviews were
so serious like i felt like i was doing stand-up comedy when
i was doing my interview i cried during my i actually cried
like i had oh yeah no that's gonna be too
me but they're like they asked me gaming questions because
the original cut had gaming so they had like like gaming
stuff there and i was like oh yeah my favorite games are
like my favorite games are apex legends maverick and i was
like talking about my gaming experience and everything i was
like yeah i love gaming and i see you guys you're like yeah
like v-tubing changed my life like oh my guys like and i'm
just like yeah i fucking love gaming i feel like i need to
say something now And that is...
Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
What is it?
I also had a bit of a silly one to the point where the staff
halfway through had to stop me and were like, Rin, could you
try and be less funny for the next one?
Rin, lock the heck in.
Lock in, Rin.
And I'm like, I don't know.
I know, man, this is just a reflex to me.
I'm not even doing this.
I'm not even doing this consciously, man.
It's so funny.
Oh, my...
Dude, can a fan out there please make me personally an edit
where it's me, crying and then it cuts to rin saying
something extremely often and then it cuts to maybe mouth
saying something like very heartful and then it cuts like
just like direct like don't keep doing the mr beast pose
again exactly exactly like i just yeah i didn't even hit
that without even being asked like the sad music put the put
the raindrops on the screen and then just like hard cut yeah
all of you guys had like cool poses i did the mr beast pose
i got what i did the mr beast
options they were both good i it was hard to choose you know
the other option that they filmed for me was the deep meme
so you guys know the deep meme where the deep from the boy
yeah wait what yeah what he's talking about okay i'll show
you the video it's a good video it's called it's like the
deeps and have you guys ever watched the boys yes yes yes
yes so you know how they're how okay wait you know how he he
just back his show and then the music plays and he turns
around dramatically he's like i i like hummed it so clearly
in my mind i hummed the the notes to it when i did that
entrance and i'm sad that i'm sad that like no copyright
infringement intended no copyright infringement intended
listen that footage exists somewhere we can get it yeah it's
just waiting see the light of day so i did that and the mr
beast one and they it's so hard to choose i know it's so
good it's so good so it was between those two choices were
my entrance because i i did two they wanted me to do a cool
pose for my entrance but during the interview i did
instinctually just hit the absolute cinnamon pose at least
five times i don't know how many times it's in like the
finished product but like i just i just do it i can't stop
it now i'm doing it right now yeah i feel there for the
vibes honestly I was I was the first one so I was so nervous
like okay I'm gonna lock in I like do what I do for
auditions when I'm really nervous like I just become a
virgin of myself that like is confident I'm like no I'm
playing a character that of me that is called like I know I
was so locked in to being confident yeah that's true it is
yeah yeah it's my little trick I'm playing a character and
while she was doing all of that I was playing Street Fighter
in the other office you were actually it's not even bit is
it i know and then joki came and crashed mine which i'm not
sure is in the in the final but it was pretty funny not this
one yeah because i was supposed to we were all supposed to
crash each other's thing unfortunately i was at the mall and
couldn't crash at rin's place because i was abandoned i was
crazy i was just like i'm sorry rin it's gonna you're gonna
be there for a while of a jeans store to buy jeans like okay
yeah i got new shoes though rin instead of crashing i got
new shoes so happy for you how was your experience rin
during not rin sorry rms how was your experience during like
no no no ask how rin is doing you've had your time rin
you've got it it's true
little different because I wasn't there for the vocab.
I actually had somebody, well, through magic.
Yeah, through magic.
You were there in spirit.
I was there in spirit and through magic, which was very
scary.
I came alive, you know?
But I felt like I was being haunted the entire time.
It was great.
It was nice.
They asked me a lot of questions and I was really nervous
and I'm like, man, do I sound stupid or what the heck?
Oh my God.
Listen, you've got the other three of us in the room.
Like, don't worry.
That reminded me, guys, Okay, so the reason why we were at
T1 Studio, like, the only reason why we were able to get a
T1...
It's because you wanted to go!
No, no, no, it's because the people that were interviewing
us, they are working on a documentary for Faker.
So they got a...
They were able to get us a tour because they were already
working with T1.
So I thought that was really cool because I was like, oh, oh
my God.
You work with Faker, and we're technically one degree away
from Faker if you think about it.
And Doki was going crazy.
But basically the same guy that's going there.
It's practically the same guy.
I was, you know, bird watching, but I was Doki bird
watching.
Because her reactions to things were so funny.
So I was just bird watching Doki the entire week.
I feel like that's something we could do with this.
There is a meme here.
There's definitely some content here.
It's an unpolished gem.
All right.
Should we talk about Off-Kai itself and like the booth and
stuff?
Oh yeah.
All right.
Omelie, since you brought up, you should start.
Okay.
If you are there physically at Off-Kai, which you should be,
come by, have fun.
We have, there's going to be a booth for the wild card club.
So you can come by in person, check it out and take photos
and stuff.
And we're also going to have lockers at Off-Kai that are
individually designed to kind of us as if we had lockers
like in a physical club like actual big metal ones that you
could show a lot of nods around so you know take your pick
merch and stuff based around us and also we we brought up
some personal items to add to the locker yeah they're
curated to us so you can like be like i wonder whose locker
this is oh a toad plushie some of the stuff we had to ask
the staff specifically hey can you go out and buy this and
you're gonna look in there and you're gonna be interesting
what are some items that you guys have in your law i
actually didn't take a super hard look at your guys's so i'm
excited to see it in person what are some like things that
you have in there that well to my i was like can you just go
on ebay and like find a wee bounce board just stick it in
there well to my chat my chat will know this but i brought
joki prime the original plushie to the locker so you can see
it no no no it's not a cute okay never mind it's not a
future guest this is the humong killers i mean technically
yes technically a fifth member of the wildcard club i'll
show you you're gonna see it you're gonna see it and then
you'll understand i need to remember where i put it i need
to remember where i put this photo but when understand why
it's it's not cute wait no i think you two saw it in person
i because i brought it we must have because you would have
had to bring it with you was it the little one that you had
around with you taking photos of no no that's the that's the
cute one that's the that one's cute i didn't see the other
one i want to know i want to know the ugly one yeah i want
to see the ugly duckling honestly he is he wait is it the
tomato no no it's let's just he is the ugly duckling uh is
it jokie is it like is it you as a plushie well it was
technically the very first draft of the plushie but then
you're like oh that can't be that bad no no don't worry you
don't worry i've seen the horrors i've had some people
believe it's like also there's a reason we have quality
assurance for these things before we let you guys show it so
brave so brave also like one in five plushies like in
pre-production is balding like that's just that I believe
in.
A plushie's naked, too.
Naked!
Yeah, no panties.
Yeah, it's naked.
I know, where did I save it?
Oh my gosh.
It is as, it is as naked as I describe it.
I guess we'll see it soon.
We'll see it soon.
All right, why did you guys bring up what you guys brought
to your locker while I try to find it?
Locker, locker.
I have cinnamon roll, of course.
Of course.
Yeah, yeah.
And a common writer because I like common writer uh and um i
also had the model oh good god sorry not to cut you off but
i've seen i've seen the homunculus now oh my god that how do
you say these days he's a little bit shocked did your dog
get it oh my god okay well i mean i thought you were i
thought you were just being hard on yourself but i can see
you were not so here's like left to right compared I have
three of them, but so do you see Why did you need three?
They're like gingerbread man We are the donkey legs feed off
Wait, no one looks like it has teeth What is going on?
Oh, it's horrible.
So you see that the locker I brought dokey pride will be at
the lockers guys, you see it in person That looks like
something out of Madoka, like a horror It looks like if
Shrek was a horror movie And the little gingerbread man like
didn't make it At the end of the movie perfect as he is so
the that's the first draft for the you see the first draft
and the final draft so that turned into that is that crazy
that no way it's like it's like a fucked up evolution the
evolution it's like one of those charts that shows like how
we evolved from like homo sapiens or homo sapiens sapiens
sapiens or whatever did you show your chat can i show my
chat yeah Yeah, you can show it.
Yeah, you can show it.
Don't worry, my chat knows about Doki.
My chat knows about this guy.
It'd be really funny if like one day you couldn't make it to
something.
You're like, don't worry, Doki's right here.
It's just a PNG.
It's just a PNG of that.
No, guys, Doki's here.
You can't, don't you see?
He's right here with us.
He's right here.
Now, do you see the vision when I said it looks like Shrek
was a horror movie and the gingerbread man didn't make it?
Do you see the vision, Jeff?
I see the vision.
I feel like I can hear them in my mind just going like, I'm
Doki Bogged in unison.
I'm Doki- No, I'm Doki.
No, I'm Doki Bird.
I'm Doki Bird.
I also gave them my minions glass.
I have a minion Sawaski Bob figure and I...
You got the minions.
You bought that?
I bought a joke.
Is everything okay at home, Doki?
It was true.
Wait, hold on.
You bought it for yourself?
Yeah, I bought it for myself.
I was on the website and I was showing Ted.
I'm like, Chad, look at all this shit.
And I was like, look at this.
I got a crystal minion.
Who the fuck would buy that?
It's you.
He would buy it.
I would buy it.
I was at New York.
I was at New York Comic Con and Swaski had a booth there.
And then it was like the, they were showing the minions.
No, not a good excuse for the record.
I was just like, oh my God.
I need this.
I need the minion.
Swazki Bob figure I literally made a joke that was like
going forward joke he gets none of the club budget she
cannot be trusted I cannot be trusted I cannot be trusted
with money I'm sure that minion figuring out how to play the
drums because you're not gonna have any money for the girl
band at this rate I'm sorry financial responsibility where
did you put it where did you put it I just it was next to me
I get to see it whenever I play a little monitor No, I made
a joke about that.
That was like, if I won the lottery, I wouldn't tell
anybody, but there'd be signs.
And it was just like, all of them, like a collection of
them.
I just have one, though.
It's only one.
I could have bought another one, but I did.
See, I'm good.
There's all of the minions.
Yeah, I could have completed the collection.
We can't give her any of the budget.
We can't let her have it.
Yeah, I mean, I'm the only one that took the Mr. Beast
poster in our intro.
I don't think you should trust me on anything.
yeah you did like the the deep soundtrack like a primal
place for you like that was that was more instinct so cool
we were an animal program and then there was me dude i am
99.9 serious in that it's gonna be so funny i was not you're
highly overestimating how serious i was for this yeah during
my i mean they did tell you to stop making jokes you she's
just too funny please we're trying to do a serious
documentary here why don't he got to be goofy all the time
huh she can't be contained uh because uh favoritism i guess
no yay i can't believe this this was funded by swarovski the
entire time funded because i bought swarovski crystal you
know the famous music producer right what's in your locker
right what's in your locker come on are you talking to me
good morning good morning I already said I asked the staff,
hey, could you just go on eBay and buy a Wii balance board
and just put it in there?
That's just one thing in the locker, just a Wii balance.
I also asked them to get a remote.
Oh, a remote and a Wii balance board.
That must be expensive.
Is that expensive?
That is pennies today.
You know how many of those things live in landfills now?
Oh.
I'm pretty sure we have more Wii remotes on the earth than
people at this point, right?
The phrase, diamond dozen, doesn't begin to describe it.
Where he's like, I'm not done yet about the wheeze.
I'm going to let you finish.
I know I'm going to let you finish.
Go ahead.
You know what, do we, since Doki doesn't get any more
budget, do we have it in it for a Wii, one of those Wii
wheels for Maricopa, please?
When you...
I'm just going to...
I'm very passionate!
We need to have a stick!
Can we have a talk stick of who holds the...
I do have a stick.
It's okay.
I have a stick from VFO.
I have a stick with the motion controls.
When you, when you go.
Amalie has the talking stick now.
I have the talking stick.
Well, that's great.
I'm happy for you.
Really, I am.
I'm so proud.
She has the talking stick.
I have the conch.
I was gonna say, you guys have such like detailed things and
I was like, can you guys give me a jar of pickles?
So like there's literally a jar of pickles in my locker.
There is some like very curated stuff obviously some manga
and like anime that I really love But I was like can you
just put a jar of pickles in there?
It'll be easy to find I don't know if I saw it for pickles
to go off out of interest No, they'll be in a jar.
They won't be consumed until I go over to my locker and I
pop that boy open I'm gonna of course.
No, I'm not gonna be there.
Damn it.
I'm not gonna be there in person No, but wait, you can ask
them.
I'm getting a flight tonight I have to wait them vicariously
for you.
Yeah, you just ask them what's a jar of pickles for you?
Like, Alma, someone ate a pickle out of your jar.
No!
I wonder who that could have been.
The staff member standing off to the right with the
suspiciously pickle-shaped face.
Oh.
Yeah, it's gonna be really cool.
We have some personal items in the lockers as well as items
that, like, we, like, like, you know, hobbies and the
fandoms that we'd like.
There's also gonna be the locker.
Because we have to fill out a doc and be like, what's your
favorite things so they buy like that's what we like yeah i
put my first really cute my first yowie dojin is in the
locker too what wait wait i found it i found it we were
excited to bring this up every single time it's you who
starts this conversation wait wait i'm very you gotta link
this as well in the chat so my chat has always asked me
about my very first dojin that i own like the only one by
the way is the first and only one i've ever yeah I've ever
bought because it was for a rare pair so it was for a
pairing that was so rare that's so desperate for content
that I bought a dogen for the first time it's literally it's
literally the sacred text for my chat because they're like
and you just left it in California they're like can you show
it can you show it and I was like I don't know where it is
guys I legitimately don't know where I put it but like for
the locker I found it I found the Bible I've the relic the
relic has discovered the relic that that dogen is like more
than 10 years old by the way it's so it's a it's you know
like the three kingdoms dynasty warriors yeah that it's it's
a pairing from dynasty warriors it's like well everyone
needs a hobby technically yes it is fan fiction
so even with the budget restriction donkey butt finds a way
and it's gonna be in the locker so you guys can finally see
exactly what because i didn't even know what the dogen looks
like at all because like i didn't even remember what it
looked like but i found it so they'll get me to see the
sacred text in person i feel like i'm not using my villain
abilities i could have really had them try to find some
really crazy things but i was really nice yeah oh my god i
was like i was like well i guess i can't i can't really have
anything too crazy in there but i'm like
I love our, by the way, it's R18 too, so do not open it.
You're going to tell the staff this.
I'm of interest.
No, I did.
I said it's R18.
Okay, that's something.
I mean, still not brilliant, but you know.
But it's going to be in my locker, guys.
You're going to be there.
This is your legacy.
If you die tomorrow, this is what people will remember you
for.
Yeah, they'll see it.
Someone's watching us, and this is their first impression of
you.
That is what you're saying.
It's okay, I'm referring now.
an iron mouse i'm not really super familiar with the stokey
bard character i'm oh okay i'm reformed now i'm i'm i've
recovered i've recovered i will never forget this about you
though i i'm gonna look this up i'm gonna i'm gonna always
ask you what this is by putting this on your tombstone you
know yeah did i was like the only one with the wild stuff on
my did anyone have any wild things wait no there's no way
there's no it's the way i'm the only one what's the wildest
thing what's the wildest thing in your in your locker mouse
um uh which cinema roll is the craziest of them just
cinnamon rolls well no because i i asked for bad bunny i
guess he's pretty wild um our adventure i guess i don't know
cute i love it i can't wait to see them all if you guys see
them in person you gotta take photos and like tag us yeah
you gotta take photos you're gonna be like a hashtag thing
going around.
But now that I'm done, I should have put some Yuri stuff in
there.
I didn't know.
I was like, balance the scales.
You know what?
I did put some alien stage in there, I think, in mine, so.
Oh, nice.
Oh, love it.
I like how, oh my God, wait.
I like how I'm looking at my document in this, like,
favorite manga volumes, and then it's the because, you know,
oh, God.
It's really this.
Oh, no.
Is this it?
Yeah, this is it.
I'm looking Oh my, that's a lot of tongue.
Whoa!
Well, I'm glad those young boys seem to be having a good
day.
Don't show up to smash the on stream.
I will keep it as a surprise.
But look at what they categorized.
They wrote this.
That's so good.
Someone was paid to deal with this.
Someone's paid good money, hopefully.
And this is going to be inside your locker?
Is it going to be?
All of a sudden you have to show ID to get into off guy who
knows why that could be.
I just like how they wrote it as favorite manga volumes and
I was like, what's that?
You're like, what did I, what did I submit again?
Yeah, what did it?
Oh, that's what I submitted.
So funny.
So yeah, I think my locker might be the most, maybe like not
on theme compared to everybody else.
That's fair.
It's definitely on some sort of theme.
I'll give you that much.
I know I asked for them to...
I was like, you could put something Bracken related in
there, but I don't think it was able to be found.
There's so little Bracken, like, merch available.
The Bracken from the Lethal Company?
That's Maya.
That's my husband.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, so.
Just a little word for it.
I'm excited.
Yeah, yeah.
Your boyfriend, the Bracken.
Yeah.
No, we're married, so.
Oh, shit.
Are you still married?
I'm still married.
married yeah yeah it's like an on and off thing look red
someone made it i believe oh my god oh no we have the trans
power we have the png oh baby i'm giving this to my mods
mods work oh my god it started get to work that was not that
was quite fast that's beautiful put it in my tag and
everything they really can i can i ask for some more things
to get done real fast that was so Yeah, I'm telling you to
have to sorry.
Let's do some thumbnails.
Yeah, I'll put Rin behind all of us right here.
Oh, no.
That was so...
Oh, brother.
No, please.
Do not fucking look behind you right now.
Anything with that, please.
She cloned herself.
Look, everybody...
Everybody look really cute, kid.
Everybody pose cute.
Chee.
Yay.
I don't remember if there's anything else.
I'm looking through the sheet right now.
Is what talk about anything else in the in the sheet?
I'm worried that at this point, it's going to be like, okay,
guys, that's great.
I feel like it's the question of question of five.
I think that's important.
Let me see.
I can do it.
Yeah.
Wait, I have to find my sheet.
All of us reading because we have to wait.
Okay, which number?
Okay, wait.
I'm looking at four, five, and six.
Oh, okay, yeah.
So since we mentioned that the Wildcard Club is like
music-orientated, you might be out there being like, well, I
don't really do music.
Can I join the club?
Yes, you can.
Well, yes, you can join the club, but the application itself
is only open to VTubers.
But you can join the club and like follow along and be a
part of the club that way.
You don't have to like sing or do something like musically
in the club with us.
You can still join the club and be like a...
a non-singing member if you want to follow along so i feel
like it's worth to say uh it is music based but they're not
like uh we're not necessarily like looking for the best
singer or anything yeah it's like again you know Amma you
being here makes sense mouse you've been here makes sense
Dokki you know you've got some you've got some bangs there
we're there you know we're out what what are you talking
about i thought I'd recommend it for this oh thank you you
guys I like your song um you guys you're so really good
singers too, you know?
I got to be on stage with Doki recently.
Oh yeah, we did!
Rit acts like...
Rit acts like this.
Yeah, Rit, you're so much better.
You're so...
Yeah, I agree.
I am good at a very specific kind of song.
You release more songs than me.
I think I have like three songs.
And that goes to show...
You guys are all amazing.
You don't have to be singing focused.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to apply for this thing.
Yes, it's not open to just singing VTubers.
Like, you could be a dancer.
You could have some other talent.
if you have like your own unique appeal you are welcome to
apply you doesn't have to be like just singing you could
have something else some other talent that you do really
incredibly or um i mean like three of us in this group are
the funny man so like you know apparently anything goes
which sorry so who's not the funny man which wait wait wait
you want to call that out funny one that guy who's about to
hit donkey with the steel chair i don't like the look in his
eyes oh yeah um and it's not just us like it's not us that's
like selecting the member as you guys know there is like
you'll find out more on off cat but there is like a global
big company that we're working with global music group that
is helping us as well um and uh but yeah they'll be looking
at people who fit the plans and directions they they have in
mind and like i said you don't have necessarily be the best
singer um they'll be selecting people who stand out to them
and have something compelling about them and yeah um each of
us because you're going to be like in in either of our teams
or groups so uh it's not like all of us together like not me
and amalie armas and rin together in a group we each are
going to be part of a specific uh genre or group that you're
applying to so you want to be on like yokey bird's team
which is the girl band um then you apply my team and stuff
like that so you're not applying for like a the whole
wildcard club you're applying for individual groups so yeah
pick which genre you think you fit the best yes and more
information on how to apply and all of that will be talked
about at off yeah better but you don't have to stress about
it now there's no deadline yet don't worry there's there's
no dates yet so yeah yeah everything will be revealed at off
guy and if you're just tuning in we are we will be streaming
that panel as well so you don't have to physically be at off
guy just if you're just tuning in you're like what what did
i miss i mean god knows like geographical location is not
going to be a problem if you want to apply because like we
are we are really struggling to get things scheduled because
we're just all in different time zones so like don't worry
but you could be on the moon yes i mean also possible
reasons if you notice that mousy and i hosted the
announcement Rin and Amalee will be hosting the post-off
kite Aftertalk where we will go over Yeah, me and Mousy will
be there on their streams Rin will be on YouTube Amalee will
be on Twitch And we'll be talking more about like After
everything is revealed We'll go into depth and then Mousy
can finally talk about the Korea stories Finally And
everything is revealed Can't wait to post photos of me and
my little...
John Faker's master plan.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I mean, I can't wait.
Oh, I wonder if we could talk about how we were...
Oh, yeah, I'll type it out just in case we were not allowed
to talk about it.
Oh, okay, okay.
There's some stuff we're keeping secret still for the panel,
so we want to make sure that...
Yeah.
We still have stuff.
Once again, we're V-Tubers.
We're legally not allowed to do an announcement that's just,
like, smooth and straightforward.
It's not how this works.
that i don't know we can't i don't know what that means i
don't know what that means either i do i i believe it's in
the if you go to youtube they have they have it on one one
of the thumbnails yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah so each of us
was actually sent uh replicas of the outfits that we of the
shirts that we wore for uh our thumbnails and because that
outfit is our key visual so we each we'll post photos of
that later yeah yeah yeah i'll post photos when royal mail
actually delivers it to me it's been several weeks come on
guys any day now yeah it looks really cute though i don't
know and we oh cute yeah they'll be displaying those outfits
as well at afkai um at the booth so you guys can see the
replica outfits of it in person as well i think they can if
they use that picture for the thumbnail i mean they did they
did yeah if you if you go to youtube and just type in like
wildcard club, the thumbnails pop up.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
So you see like in the trailer and everything.
So, yeah, our little shirts are like individualized, like as
if our characters like made them like customized to
ourselves.
You know how like sometimes you take a band shirt and you're
like, I'm going to cut off the sleeves or I'm going to add
little lacer, little grommet.
I'm going to tie dye it or something, yeah, I guess.
Each of our shirts are uniquely customized to all of us.
And that will be the, we each have our own.
own version of it and we can it's going to be displayed at
uh off guy as well and i believe you can win it one too oh
yeah i remember they were talking about that trails i'm like
i love trails you know no way how did you know me wait i
want to win another shirt yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna enter in
as all my different aliases wow someone entered in as amalie
as monarch as amanda lee hmm interesting yes there will be
my regular shirt's in the wash right now i i just need
something whilst laundry's going uh by the way okay i could
talk about i remember it by the way this was a this was a
three-hour meeting we were in oh yeah i talked about it to
my stream it's a three-hour meeting kind of project don't
let anyone tell you we don't work for this and then i i
stream right after our meeting and then i was just like i
just got a three-hour meeting guys i'm so tired i so this is
but don't i remember our three hour meeting i it's it was a
lot it's a very large project worked on by many many
passionate people i'm sorry there will be another meeting
merch oh yeah it's okay mousy it's you were we're glad you
escaped i couldn't be in it no tell our stories no mousy
it's a good thing that's okay If you're so sorry, take my
place next time.
As Rin was like, I'm so hungry and I was eating chips.
And I was just like, I'm one day.
Were you muting?
Because I didn't hear you snack once.
That's so funny.
I started crunching.
And everyone was like, I'm so hungry, guys.
No.
But the meeting was so long because we had so many
incredible things that we're planning to share with you
guys.
So a lot to go over.
I was asking because I remember this from the meeting where
basically there will be merch.
it's like a showcase of the merch itself.
So you can order it online later.
So the shirts that we are wearing, that can be ordered
online, like a regular shirt, but you can win.
Yeah, it's not going to be limited to off, Kai.
Yeah.
And if you're of the creative mind, you can customize yours
to be like ours.
Yeah, so you can pre-order it.
You don't know which captain you want to, you know, be
under.
You can like maybe customize them like theirs.
It's kind of cute.
Yeah, and then like we said earlier, we're going to have a
panel at off kai at sunday on next sunday at 12 p.m p.m pt
yeah but it'll be there in person in off kai and also online
on our streams yeah so i will be offline our streams will
all restreaming the uh panel as well so we won't have fomo
and they'll have more details more info like we can't give
you guys might still be confused what the fuck is a wild to
understand that's what we said as well yeah that that's also
fair i'll go over it one more time before we wrap up but
there's only so much we can say right now because we're
annoying yeah because we want to more majority of the
information we like to pretend we're cool and mysterious but
we're just vtubers so it's a bit tough bill we're we're
making it a mystery you know what is wildcard club to you
yeah that's mr wildcard club i think No, no way.
I hope you guys are excited for the announcement in the
future and the things that are on the horizon.
The near future, finally, for once.
You actually get like a date when things are happening.
We have a date now, no teases.
I know.
We've been working on this for so long and so is the whole
team.
So it's really cool to see it come to fruition.
We've been very stressed out, all of us, not just us, but
the team behind us as well.
But like in a fun way.
All big projects are worth it.
Yes, but in a fun way.
Yeah, I mean, we got to go to Korea.
I thought that was really fun.
Dude, that was incredible.
It was also, like, crazy to meet you guys, like, for the
first time at IRL.
That was just, like, really cool.
We got to, like, drink together and shop together and hang
out, and you guys got seven days of me, which wasn't that
exciting.
Masi got to tag along with us, too.
Yeah.
She had to go to the...
That was really fun.
I'm so glad to go.
And we all got to be sleep-deprived, because time zones were
fucked.
Oh, my God.
I felt like it was, like, a whole work day.
it was like early in the morning all the way to night we
would get out like relatively early and we'd come back quite
late and i think every single night we were just like okay
that was fine i'm going to pass out it was like nine or nine
a.m to like sometimes 10 or 11 p.m days like very almost
very conventionally where i was just like i i just think i
can't do this today and i just had to go have a lie down it
was funny because i'm good thank you i brought my uh my
switch to to play Pocopia and I was like I can't do my day
job right now because that game is literally just like
you're just like doing the requests and I was like I can't
do their little requests today I'm too late I gotta I gotta
get some sleep you can work on your own waterfall
oh my god it's finally out the wild card club is finally out
now go check it out go check it out on YouTube give it some
love post some comments and it's gonna be a lot ongoing it's
an ongoing project so it's not like we do this and we're
done.
This isn't like a one and done.
It's not one and done.
It's gonna be a big time.
Yeah, and then we want to make sure to emphasize that it is
a project focused on music and groups.
So we're planning on building more on it later on in Off Guy
and we're looking for members to join us too.
Please join us.
That could be you.
That's a threat.
Join my club.
No.
My two.
Wait.
No.
They're all joining our club.
This is the wildcard club.
Join the club.
Are they going to be like I'm going to join a team Yeah,
join my team No, join my team Join my club Join my team Join
all Okay, no, you can't join all our teams by the way It's
one only You have to pick one Choose You got a choose Choose
who you want Yeah, choose which captain Which captain will
you choose?
Yeah, it's like game of thrones Yeah, it's like who will sit
upon the throne It's like completely different And with no
similarities Yeah Oh my gosh He's so excited!
He's so excited!
Yeah!
Join!
What is your dog's name?
Doki.
Wait, really?
You like your dog after yourself?
I'm so humble.
Yeah, I named my dog after myself.
Wait, that's so funny actually.
I love myself so much.
I need my dog after myself.
Wait, so when you go to the vet and you're like, oh, are you
Doki's mom?
Like, do they like...
Like, for Doki?
For Doki?
Look, Doki and...
Who's asking?
Here for your rabies shot?
Doki, here for your rabies shot?
Hey, no.
No.
Hey.
Doki's so excited.
He's so excited.
But I call him dad.
Has Doki been like eating and drinking water okay?
You're like, yeah, Doki has.
Yeah, like.
No, Doki, you can't get up on the sofa.
That's for people.
So to avoid confusion, I call him dad because it's like Doki
Amber Doge.
So then his, so then on stream, I call him dad just to avoid
confusion.
So like chat would be like, which Doki are you talking
about?
And I'm like, well, I'm talking about my dog.
Like Doki Amber Doge?
So I call him my father instead, which calls him.
There's no confusion whatsoever.
His male name's Amber.
The dog is a middle name?
Your dog doesn't?
Doki Amber?
Yeah, Doki Amber Doge.
He has a middle name.
Wait, do you have dad?
Is that a normal thing?
No.
I gave him a middle name so I could call him dad, so it
would make sense.
Wait, that's so cute.
I thought maybe I was like not treating my dogs with enough
respect by not giving them...
I'm one of my dogs.
His name's James, but his legal name is Sir James.
It's just a little bit like...
Last name, sir.
Last name, James.
United your own dog.
James, sir, is having a stunk.
In the country of Amelie.
Call it ambulance.
Pretty good.
But yeah, I can't believe we finally...
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe we finally announced it, though.
We don't have to keep it a secret anymore.
I've been so nervous about spoiling it.
I've been so careful.
Oh my God, I've been so scared.
Yeah, I was so glad.
Still not out of the woods yet, but like, you know, any day
now.
Well, that's why I was like, guys, you guys take over.
You say what you want because I was like, if it's me, if I
start talking, I'm going to steal everything and I can't do
that.
No, go ahead, Mouse.
Here, the stick is yours.
You have the stick.
No, no.
Take the stick from me, please.
What do you want to talk about?
I could tell you possibly about this.
Oh, no.
All right.
Mousey, what do you want to say?
What do you want to say?
I gave you the stick.
Yeah, I'm going to talk about it.
Guys, I'm just happy to be here.
Nice.
Safe.
good we didn't we didn't get any messages from the server we
didn't so so we i think we did a good job i was nervously
checking as if we had said something i was like have we said
anything wrong so either we're doing good or they've all
gone to bed oh it's true there's only one way to find out
right we did saw we did so anyway here's my 12 month
timeline for this project oh my god i remember i was just
like i was because like the videos were out before the
announcement too So we were like, we got to make sure, we
got to make sure nobody can find it.
We got to have a chat.
A few of you did because you're good little sleuths.
Yeah, and I know you love a couple.
I didn't see anyone talk about it during my World Cup thing.
So I think everybody, my chat was just watching the World
Cup.
I think they might have been busy then.
It's true.
I think there was something more going on.
There was something crazy going on.
There was something crazy.
But yeah, I was like, we were having our conversation.
we were like trying to talk about the wild card club because
i had to delay the stream because of the world cup and then
i almost missed the only goal that spain scored because i
was like i was like typing back fiercely me like oh and i
was like oh i disappear now don't mind me i was just like
i'll let them handle it they can deal with this at a certain
point we were like dokey take your time take your time yeah
like dokey just disappeared from the group chat like i legit
like everyone was just like talking about it i had no i
think i did ask in the group chat at one point i just heard
someone scream like they got hit by a car outside my window
did someone score a goal and you're like it's complicated
yeah i was just like yes and no oh my but i'm glad to
finally have this out now and this is why we were all so
fucking busy the last how many continue to be so fucking
busy for the next god knows how long agreed yeah there's
gonna be more announcements at off guy like you might be
like is that all you know we're gonna have more stuff
announcing during off guy panel and post off guy so this is
gonna be a wild time for us it's something a wild time yeah
i did say i mean i thought it was when they reached out to
me to do this i was like me like yeah me too i like i kept
checking like what oh no i kept like checking emails being
like is this spam like am i am i gonna get am i gonna get
like one guy i was talking to your manager like there's no
way and then your manager was like yeah i'm gonna have to
sit you down for this one yeah we're like wait they want us
like yeah but we're but we're us i was like i was I'm just
like, I'm just a meetover, man.
What the?
What do you mean?
Oh, look, a gift mouth in the hole.
And I remember my manager, like, wanted to ghost the email
because he thought it was this, like, a phishing email.
And I was just like, don't just reply.
Just reply.
Maybe like, what if it's real?
I know.
I wasn't sure if it was real, too.
And I might, like, very first.
So if you're wondering who we're working with, someone worth
phishing, apparently.
It's a global music group.
that's all we can say for now it's all you can know i i i
thought i did not i don't know i was just what like we're
gonna release like original songs like with like that's
crazy just to think about yeah it's gonna be music we're
gonna be in the music that's gonna be pretty wild it's
pretty We're gonna do music, guys.
Oh, my God.
I've actually been wanting to do, like, more stuff like
this.
Like, it's just, like, it has been, like, my goal.
Like, for the few...
Everyone's like, what's your five-year plan?
I was like, I'd like to do this.
Like, more music and stuff.
Like, um...
Damn, you guys have plans?
This just, like, came on a platter.
I was like, yeah, let me get some of that, like, eating it
up.
Yeah, I'm always down to do more music, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think after the initial, like, this is definitely a scam.
Like, after we all realized we were all, like,
that you know i had my very first meeting with them it was
actually i was actually going to a convention and like my
meeting time was coming up and i was like in line to check
in and i was like like i was so nervous because like the
line was going so slow and i was like i'm gonna be late i'm
gonna be late for the meeting and then i like ran to my
hotel room and like i was like it i had like like like like
get changed and get like dressed and like put makeup on i
was like i was so nervous but it was it was so cool i know
wait if we're if we're talking very briefly about the first
meeting we had with uh john music himself yeah i i just need
to know yeah did anybody else was anybody else given the
powerpoint with anime luigi in it what um i can't say i
recall that he was just in the background i think they were
using the art as an example of like a vibe or something but
I I zoned out for three seconds and I was like what's anime
Luigi doing in the background I think it was just you I
think that are you sure hey I'm gonna go find that image
because I took a picture because I was like there's no way
that's no why is anime Luigi am I holding up how many
fingers I think like because I know for me I was like I was
pitched this so Oh my gosh, Dad just wants to get involved
right now.
Doki, stop barking into the mire.
Okay, I found it.
I don't know if I can show this because I don't know who to
attribute the art to.
But he was there.
I'm like, sure, I'm like, sure.
Wait, what?
What is this?
It's Anime Luigi.
I'm just going to say, I would remember this.
I have no idea who drew this.
I did not see this.
I did not see this either.
I feel like I would remember this.
I'm going to ask for the PowerPoint so I can go back and
look at it.
I feel like I would remember this, honestly.
it's it's just like i think it's like yeah no it's just
anime i remember because it was like me and i mouse were the
first two that side i think i got brought on and they were
like hey you cool with working with mouse uh doki and armor
and i'm like yeah you got like you got the pitch deck you
got the you got they made a pitch deck for you because like
for me my first meeting it was like a verbal thing um for it
like and they were like oh yeah they're like oh how would
you guys should we ask and stuff like that like we were
thinking about asking these people and i was just like yeah
i'm cool i'm cool hey i think mommy was like we're talking
to these guys and i was like i love those guys oh my god and
then omelette i remember omelette messaged me and then she
was like so i heard you're gonna be doing this i was like a
little bird told me who was it like what little bird like me
i'm the little bird yeah i got really well i was so they
were like you cannot about this i was like oh let me not
talk to anybody then okay and so i was like i didn't tell
anybody so i got really scared i was like who told you who
was it why i signed i i had an nda i had yeah dude you were
it was so funny in your messages you were like what like you
like i can't i don't remember what you said but it was like
sorry can you can you repeat that like yeah i was like Who
snitched?
I'm not getting in trouble here.
I didn't say anything.
I was like, a little birdie told me you're on the project.
And you were like, oh, I don't know about that.
What's the little bird?
I was so scared.
I was so paranoid because they were like, you can't tell
anyone.
I know.
And then I had to awkwardly be like, oh, it's, I'm also on
the, it's me.
I'm here too.
I was like, oh, okay.
Oh, we cool.
We cool now.
and then there's something we like to call a friendier right
oh yeah we had all signed at that point so i i knew it was
sick yeah and i did i didn't tell anyone no like i remember
like mint was and mint and matara was asking me about it and
i was like i can't i cannot say anything guys i i don't want
to get in trouble no no no no i was like you'll find out
later i told matara i was like you'll find out soon i can't
you'll find out at off kai at 12 p.m pm that sounds like a
you're gonna find out whether you like it or not matthew
yeah oh no um but yeah anyway that's the wildcard club yeah
the project's over now we can all go no no no no the project
is still going guys the project is still going we did it we
did it guys we're now We announced it!
We did it!
Yay!
It was the first part of the announcement.
More to follow.
Part 1 of 12.
Part 1.
But make sure to check out the documentary.
Yeah, go give it some love.
Leave some comments for us.
Wait, can we?
Would they let us watch it on stream?
I was like, maybe I'll just watch it later.
Oh yeah, we were supposed to watch it.
Oh, I forgot about that part.
Yeah, we were gonna watch it.
Oh.
I thought we were just watching the trailer.
I mean, we can watch it if you guys want to watch it.
They said we could watch a little bit.
Oh, do they want the views to go to the channel?
which would be understandable yeah i think maybe we should
just let them watch it on their own time then yeah yeah yeah
yeah but yeah i'll link it to documentary we did talk a
little bit about it we talked it's a multi-part thing so
obviously not all of it is up right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
the magical thing about youtube is you can upload more
videos which is really which is awesome i liked how my room
looked like between two ferns with dokey bird because there
was two ferns next to us.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
It's so funny.
It literally looks like between two ferns with Gaphamactus
or whatever his name is.
Oh, they said we could watch the first three minutes.
That's just the intro.
I mean, we can.
Which makes sense.
Now you've said that.
Yeah, it's mostly the trailer.
Yeah, it's mostly.
It's a little different.
It's a little bit different.
There are some different cuts and some different like VO.
All right.
Do we do you guys want can watch or you want to watch the
first three minutes and then three minutes oh i got to see
this room physically yeah oh yeah well i have to move it
around i don't know i don't know if i can show this put it
on my screen but i'll link it and i'll tell you when we
start it so you guys can watch with us i don't got another
watch along i'll share it with you guys so it was synced up
i think it's this one i have 20 tabs i'm sorry i'm sorry i
disappeared this all right all right all right we all ready
to watch the first three minutes yes i'm down all right chat
we're gonna do wait i need to make you guys small okay wait
we gotta get tiny we gotta get tiny yeah real tiny i still
like how the red number two is behind us he's part of the
club too i know he's just like been there like looming over
us I wanted to get, like, rigged.
Like, the chair is kind of, like, teetering.
Yeah.
Will a chair show up in episode two as well?
God, I hope so.
It's better.
In Rin's locker, there's just a folded chair for no reason.
There's nothing else.
There's just a chair.
Yay.
We're small now.
Yay!
All right.
Are you guys ready to count down?
Yes.
And we'll be quiet.
All right.
Three, two, one play oh who the hell is that oh my god who's
that that's me you can tell they don't be my input on this
because for some reason the wild card club features bookworm
adventures the PC game the
editing is crazy I would say that I really Like, you know,
like, I won't say serial killer font, but you know what I'm
saying.
Ransom note.
Yeah.
The ransom note.
The ransom note font.
We're scrapping.
That's what the wild card is.
Yeah, that's the wild card club.
Oh no.
Ha ha.
Nerd.
Here's what I cry.
I was just talking about, like, how lived experience, and
that went in the background.
And we're like, we gotta, we gotta fucking get you.
You cut it out.
But I actually cried there.
they got british there i did get a little british sorry
that's scary i don't know there's mousy yay that's me yeah
that's true i'd hope it's true it's in the documentary now
not just like people like that it's not moral
watching this also makes me realize you guys have so many
anime projects and I'm just like oh I'm all let's plan out
yeah you got the the dictionary game that's my shining
highlight of my career mr.
B the mr.
B's pose oh yeah that's me talking me sucking up to people
see
like you guys are interviews are so touching and i was like
yeah i'm gonna talk about the story of how i almost failed
university because i started gaming no yeah but that's
because you're the cool one you're the cool one i can't help
it i'm a pisces i'm sensitive oh there's you like who the
hell is this guy who's john meetover i don't know but i kind
of like him
I had to ask that several times They didn't freeze up by the
way.
I held that post like a solid 45 seconds video now the first
three minutes
If you want to watch the rest of it, you got to go check it
out It's on YouTube.
That's 12 minutes.
It's incredible They should have like cut like between like
I'm really a messy like with me and Rin like just break up
between you two very different coins.
Like, it's just the positions of our interviews.
I need to see that cut where it's like Anna and Maus talking
about very honest, open, emotional, like, subject matter for
them, and then just Doki with Doki with the Mr. Beast pose,
me coming in with a steel chair.
They asked me a lot of, you know, they were like, so tell us
about all the things that make you sad.
And I was like, oh, okay.
No, no, no, you know, they were like, tell us about your
life.
And I'm like, it's not very happy, but okay.
I tried my best.
Don't worry, the juxtaposition is going to be great.
Yeah.
I know we haven't shot Ryn's interview yet, but we can just
tell.
Hey.
I gotta go check it out.
If you do check it out, let us know what you think about it.
Yippee!
We will be stalking the comments.
This has been a real vain on the inside.
Oh my god, wait.
That one is show.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I don't know if I can show it.
You got permission to show some, right?
I just got permission to show videos, but I have to mute the
video because there was one where we were doing the
macarena.
It's...
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe don't commit blatant copyright infringement.
It was what we were doing.
On the announcement stream.
That full DMCAing and outing systems.
Doing the chacha snide during the motion.
Damn, you too?
Oh, I have this, though.
I think this one is a good photo.
You want to show it on stream?
Oh, that's cute.
That's us flicking.
No, no, no!
Oh, God.
That's pretty good, yeah.
I sent it for approval, but I haven't heard back yet.
But in my suit, in my suit, my friend got a video of me
physically doing 6-7.
And then it jump cuts to my model on doing 6-7.
So I want to let you know that that is coming.
That's on its way.
chat wants to see it i'm gonna show it to them i'm gonna
show this one you can i'll show the this is my one my one
second of unprofessionalism i want to let you know this is
my one it was a split it's a split moment because nothing
else possibly could have been read that way no i was doing
cute poses and then rin was over here with the chair on our
back so i i said i was like i don't do my hands damn it at
least be accurate when you're slaughtering me so i'm gonna
do one 80% of my time mocapping that it's just I just don't
know my hands are wet like oh I can't find a hand oh my god
I feel a cat you're like it does yeah you're like with
towels I'm gonna wipe my hands wait you're doing middle
fingers too you just can't see because you're wearing black
gloves on a black I mean but for donkey it's in character so
it's more surprising oh if you're if you're a if you're a
viewer on my stream is perfectly in character for me too get
good gamer i have this one i'll show too let me see if it oh
where did i save it to where did i save this oh no wait i'll
show it to you guys too let me oh my god where did i save
this photo it disappeared it can you can you take it out of
the out of the server and just like yeah yeah yeah here I
was going to show this one.
See, this is where she was professional.
I think she was 6-7 here.
What am I even doing in that poem?
I think...
I know what.
I think Amali was 6-7.
Oh, you look so cute.
I think I was 6-7.
Statistically, you are.
Or I was trying to do the little, like, heart hands, but I
can't remember which.
That looks like you were mid-6-7.
And then Rin was, like, stalking you.
I look like I'm charging up to, like, take you around the
back of the head.
I'm definitely a...
i think you were like dancing in the background to like yeah
there's a there's a my too i'm doing the cha-cha slide i
didn't get approval for it but there is a point where my
model breaks like upside down it's like flipping through
dokey she's like she like did a cartwheel somehow by herself
i did not do a cartwheel but it like it's stuck and it's
really funny try to see where like there is a google drive
that we can pull images from but i don't remember like where
dokey are you twerking in this photo i know i think i was
going to be like hey little guy i thought you were throwing
it back no i was not throwing it back i was like hey there
little guy i'm like i feel like you would remember if i was
twerking i you know like you'd think you'd think i do you
know yeah you're right you'd think i would but i wouldn't
you're right you're right Wait, maybe it's in the pictures.
Oh, it is in the pictures.
There's the other stuff.
If there's, is this the folder?
Oh.
Okay, there's nothing.
Oh, wait.
Oh, everything got trashed.
Oh, it's funny.
You're sharing your screen still, so I know all your
secrets.
Yeah, we can see you, like, going through the small crisis
right now.
I see all your secrets.
Oh, you still see it?
You got to get it?
Oh, no.
I don't even remember what I was sharing.
storage I see I know all your secrets you know all my
secrets is it it uses a web browser disgusting all right
secrets God damn I shouldn't have said anything damn secrets
God and the next time you'll be able to find out secrets is
it off Kai next Sunday whenever the panel is I can't do
times on conversions because it's 1am p.m pt because it's uh
it's california time we said the same thing
sorry 12 p.m pt i uh did i say 2 p.m we said the same thing
twice yay i'm going on my way yay thank you guys so much for
hanging out and being a part of the announcement stream
thank you everyone for coming finally revealing i hope
everyone's excited for the wild club card yes i know why i'm
ready to save that money on my groceries card club all right
see you there it goes yeah join the club join the club yeah
all right you guys have a good night we'll see you next time
everyone bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye